you had a live audience for many many 28
years 28 years was it like when you
stopped having that live audience even
though it was tiring to get that going
all the time
did it feel like you fell off a cliff
did it feel like you stumbled a little
bit I it's funny I my big my uh honest
most sincere memory is I knew this needs
to stop and I've done this a very long
time
I've done every I've done this every
which way I can think of in this
specific format
um and I still think we're doing some
good work but
this is a good time to stop it this is a
good time I I'd like to
um
decide to move out of my home and and
move into a condo uh before they come
and take me out so you know but it
wasn't even that it was just this
feeling of so yes I very much the only
thing I missed there's a lot I didn't
miss but I missed the daily interaction
with writers comedy writers
um but there are other ways to get that
that I can that I can do now there are
other ways to work with creative people
without having to do a show every day
for an hour and the other thing I
um I missed was the audiences but I
found yeah my wife will tell you walk
around with Conan and when people stop
him and talk to him I I do a show for
them because I just and I enjoy it it's
like what I like to do I'm not I really
try and um make people happy so there's
another way to do that so there are all
avenues that I'm exploring where I can
still get that fix for lack of a better
term without being
uh part of a machine that's doing that
kind of volume business yeah uh but I
didn't it's funny I didn't feel
um
the day after our last show phone rang
and I picked it up and it was Bob
Newhart and he just said I just wanted
to congratulate you that was a great run
and you did a great job I was tearing up
and crying and I got off the phone and
thought
I I'm the luckiest person in the world
I'm to get a call from Bob Newhart
turned out later on it wasn't Bob Newton
it was it was me impersonating it was
you and it was a prank that you were
doing on a radio show that was really
funny yeah yeah I listened to it now and
and the new heart isn't even that good
you're like hey hey Bob Newhart here she
did a good job but I'm so needy
that I believe no but anyway you have
those moments where you think
um
you know uh it's that was fantastic uh
and and it's like you say
um you really can't have any complaints
in this business it's when you brought
that up it reminded me of
uh when I first was working in
television and I was a writer on
Saturday Night Live there was a writer
strike was announced
and I'm so lean and hungry literally
very lean and literally very hungry and
I've got this great job and suddenly
we're being told you all have to go on
the picket line
and stand up for the writer's Guild and
I thought
um
I remembered it fought my nature a
little bit because I thought well I
don't want to look like I'm complaining
because this is the greatest thing that
ever happened and but but I also
understood that this was imperative and
you got to support the writer's Guild
and this is so they gave us these signs
to hold in the picket line and the logo
was a
graphic of a manual like an old 1920s
typewriter with a big Ghostbuster slash
over it like We're Not Gonna Write
and I was walking around with these
signs feeling really self-conscious
because people on the picket line they
knew what does a working writer get you
guys get a lot of money right yeah yeah
we we do get a lot of money so what is
this all about and there were legitimate
things but not that you would explain on
a picket line so I remember being like
24 and walking and holding this sign and
then being horrified because someone
stopped me and said wait so you guys are
upset that you can't use electric
typewriters
and I was like it's not fair why should
I lose a 1920s Underwood uh but I
remember it feeling conflicted about
complaining
you know but of course these things all
will have to balance out they have to
balance out and there are things that
need to be corrected but my attitude
early on very much was
I'll do this for free I just love being
a comedy writer and you know you're not
supposed to say that out loud so now
doing the podcast you still you know you
have an audience but you don't hear them
so you just have to imagine that you're
connecting it but you know it's nice and
you've seen this Matt and I know you've
seen it Sona because when we walk around
and Paula seen it Paula Davis uh when we
walk around whether it's in New York
City or
um ever so many people come up and they
say I listen to it I listen to it in
covid it helped me uh so I'm constantly
getting feedback it's not just because
you're wearing the sandwich sign right
it says please please talk to me yeah I
will pay for compliments it is I walk
around I go to the ATM every 10 minutes
and I will give people thirty dollars if
they say something nice because we don't
even put this podcast out we tell you
it's like this is all for you wow and so
these are actors that you're hiring yeah
incredible they're very they're very
good yeah they're very good although I
was pretty sure I recognized Johnny Depp
he needed work
uh yeah so no you you get and then we do
some live ones when we do a live one
they uh they sell out there's a lot of
people there and they're very excited
and they know
they know me but they are like so
excited to see Sona they're so excited
to see Matt they know our rhythms they
know the bit players anyone who is
tangentially involved in any way with
the podcast and so we do get that
affirmation which is really nice this is
fun yeah and you travel you traveled
with the show around the country we've
done some yeah we've done some shows
here in uh we just did two shows at the
uh Beacon Theater uh in in New York City
and
um Stephen Colbert did the first one and
Tracy Morgan did the second one is
surprise guests and it was just a party
you know with no alcohol or anything but
is that a really a party then and really
no joy yeah
and not one laugh but you know kind of a
yeah yeah like a Soviet uh party yeah
you know like here's something that you
mentioned Stephen I was on Steven's show
when I was doing my uh last Broadway
play Network I saw that oh yeah and you
sat in my friend Mark's lap because he
used to go out in the audience oh yeah
it was amazing that wasn't part of the
show out of context that sounds like you
sat in my friend's Mark left he was uh
he was part of the show prostitute in
Europe yes
he looks great uh
and um yeah part of the show was that at
a certain point I would come down into
the audience and I would sit down among
them and just have it was fun uh I went
on uh Steven's show and I'm we're
talking about uh the differences between
doing live television and doing theater
and I said it occurred to me at that
moment I said well it's interesting
because what we do in theater
is tell the same story to a new audience
you tell a new story to the same
audience so it has it still has its it
has its responsibilities and
difficulties and challenges
for for us doing theater doing hundreds
of performances how do you keep that
fresh how do you keep leaning in you
have to understand and accept not only
is it your job and responsibility but
these people who paid good money have
not heard this story right so you get to
break it to them and that gives you some
juice to go on and you just have to kind
of lean in it and then you get into a
rhythm and you and you flow with it I
would think I've always thought for
myself uh because when I look at uh you
any one of your ilk who's up on a stage
owning it it brought on a Broadway
Theater I always think this would be the
The Greatest Show Business feeling in
the world because
um you know in the world I've worked in
and again I've been extremely lucky but
when I when I go to a show and I saw
Hamilton for the first time
and uh
um John Groff comes out as King George
and he has a very small part but it's
very but it's
fantastic and he destroys yeah and I
remember telling him I went backstage
and I'm you know talking to uh
lin-manuel Miranda and I'm talking to
the different people and just telling
them how much I love the show uh and I I
told
John Groff I was just saying uh I I I'm
so envious of you because I would love
it if there was some time apart for me
on Broadway where I get to come out
maybe 25 minutes into the show
kill absolutely kill and then go
backstage and eat a giant sandwich
and people like oh Conan was great
it's surprising he's only on stage for
six minutes halfway through but I would
make such a you know uh and I'd be a
total over the top ham and I thought
what a what a joy that would be and um
what a what an incredibly privileged
selfish thing to ask for
could someone out there please write
that they're still doing Hamilton why
don't you audition for sure auditions
I don't audition
of course my talk show host of course we
can just become theater actors
overnights